Con esta capacidad de de análisis,
o me llore, que siga en TikTok, ten 1 che Gustaf,
hay 1 partido con Jacome,
creer que push Demon es 1 supervillano de la peli,
sitúa tema, experto de Vox e p. P,
todo mal, venga,
no sé por dónde empezar,
supongo que por lo comenzó.
En primer lugar,
este hombre fala, da niña, capacidad de de análisis,
o cal, se me antoye 1 paradoxo.
Tengo en cuenta que de todo me Ovidio
élfica cuateima de push Demon,
Ella asume que, claro,
simplemente por no empartillar,
o apoyo de ovenegaa, ayunts,
sendo ovenegaa o partido,
a qué voto, eh, votaréis siempre,
pues que nada, que chasto, eguaí, parello co señor de Joe,
co señor Abascal.
Por otra banda,
se mella que este hombre
no entiende que puede haber gente galeguista,
nacionalista, de dereitas,
eh, que es 1 opción tan válida como a otra calquera,
vivimos en democracia,
de feito, es que ezequio Venega,
agrupamento de ideologías progresistas de izquierda,
apoyando a yunts,
está a apoyar a 1 partido conservador capitalista,
que 1 persona como EU,
con conciencia de clase,
marica, votante, dubénega,
puede estar, o unón,
a favor de 1 medida de su propio partido,
llámese conciencia crítica, rapaz,
lembra a teorías aristotélicas,
entiende que en 1/2, donde atopamos a virtud,
porque no 1 amigo, no 1, todo e Blanco o 1 Negro,
buscaos matices,
abre, amén,
te aseguro, che, que serás muy, tomáis feliz,
te falte 1 favor, anda,
e deis a De asumir a ideología política de gente